air is the new black boy a Vermont man
alongside singer Pat Boone has created
an eco-friendly car that runs on
compressed air I've seen on ABC shark
tank the dual pitch their car to a panel
of potential investors in hopes of
opening an Operations plant in America
to make their dreams a reality based on
the current prototypes the vehicle
operates on a propulsion system not a
combustion system and can reach speeds
up to 50 miles an hour the car plans to
retail for an astonishingly low price of
$10,000 all right this is exactly what
we've all been waiting for right we were
talking about the Tesla earlier I love
the test let's let you would love it I
know I haven't yet have you been in I've
been in it by having driven it's like
being in an iPad it's really it's really
really great anyway but this is even
cooler that forget electricity air a lot
of air we're surrounded by air right now
did you know that um it this seems great
to me it's cheap basic adorable it's
adorable
it looks like the car in that the Larry
David HBO movie that's like a ladybug
yeah looks like a lady but the red one
car powered by air pretty good right we
have to get my eyelids do do we yeah I
don't know what I think people actually
literally need to get behind actually
push it
after the 80 miles but it lasts for what
that's like
at in best-case scenario at less for 80
miles but isn't that just the beginning
of anything like that so that you should
say about electric cars all the time
they're only gonna go ten miles an hour
100% yeah no but never now we're all
driving electric cars well we're getting
there because of the ah yes you are got
to be paying some of your Tesla at least
yeah exactly that's up there are you
people let's go send me my dress okay I
just use I am concerned about putting
that much compressed air in a small
space and then sending it quickly down
the street where other cars could
potentially t-bone it and create a
little come it mean luckily it's like a
little balloon of explosion but still
nonetheless I don't think you're gonna
make it out of that one alive does this
not seem crazy that's like a science
reason I didn't air about not be able to
drive yes but you know the science
people are gonna be all over you
well but Aaron wouldn't explode no I
researched this a little bit and some
people are saying 100% it would explode
you have compressed air in a small space
you combine that with heat from an
explosion I mean from a from a crash and
it's an explosion right there wow I've
really I put the kibosh I know I'm just
like it's too slow it's too slow I
actually miles per hour
yeah but it'll get there that's the
point there's no but like in it you know
what I'm waiting for is the car that can
drive itself those of it that's that's
also to be there in 10 years yeah I want
to know well we've done stories on that
don't you fear though that the car
better turn on you and kill you no I
want to Carl it will Park for me yeah
all right so it's gonna parallel park
for you but then ultimately it will kill
you don't ya the robot yeah okay I mean
every week I do the road you come we
have we have we're either gonna die from
cancer or we're gonna die from a robot
like you know what evolution yeah
they're gonna overthrow all of us so
either way we're kind of screwed so I
I'd rather honestly have the robots okay
would you guys at least accept - why
don't we have a flying car forget the
I'll go with you all right forget the
aircar you don't want the aircar no
haircut what about a fine I mean I was
like well I think there's a whole that
whole like stop like traffic signal
thing like it would just be free-for-all
in the sky yeah who needs traffic see so
it's really about infrastructure you're
framing - all right that's a very fact I
thought about this - you like we get to
signal up if you really like take your
car - they like some lovely but um no
also I just feel like why don't we need
flying cars they're really cool to look
at but like practically like what would
that actually do you guys are the two
most literal guess I know we're awful
but can we talk about why I've had munis
no well he's a nature guy right so like
he likes air I suppose so I mean it's
like being like Neil Diamond is
supporting you know I don't even know so
you got to finish that I don't know I
know I just ruined her pressure quick go
I'm turning it on you you're the host go
Neil Diamond loves solar power what do
you think of this story let us know in
the comments right down below